[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler de démocratie et de tirage au
sort
je voudrais vous convaincre que tirés au
nos représentants politiques est bon
pour la démocratie
quand on pense démocratie on pense
élections cette équivalence et si bien
ancrée dans nos esprits que nous avons
du mal à la remettre en cause
alors en effet les exemples de pays où
il n'ya pas d'élections libres comme
chez nous nous laisse penser que sans
élection point de démocratie
pourtant un problème reste troublant
c'est celui de la représentativité de
l'assemblée nationale
la population active française est
composée de 22 % d'ouvriers et de 17% de
cadre à l'assemblée nationale est elle
constituée de 0 2 % d'ouvriers contre 81
% de cadres alors on me répond parfois
que c'est parce qu'on a choisi des
personnes les plus compétentes
l'assemblée nationale est composée de 26
% de femmes
va-t-on me dire aussi que les hommes
sont plus compétents que les femmes non
je ne pense pas
de nombreux mouvements font ce constat
de déconnexion entre les élites
politiques et la réalité sociale des
citoyens
un argument revient souvent le chercheur
david van reybrouck l'appel l'argument
populiste cet argument stipule qu'il
suffirait de changer de personnel
politique pour reconnecter les élites au
peuple david van reybrouck illustre cet
argument avec la métaphore de la
transfusion sanguine le sens à savoir le
personnel politique est mauvais il faut
donc le remplacer mais sans changer
l'organisme si cette thèse du qu'ils
s'en aillent tous et juste dans son
diagnostic car la représentativité de
nos assemblées est mauvaise
un simple changement de sens ne
changerait pas grand chose le problème
ne vient pas du fait qu'on s'est trompé
de bulletins à mettre dans l'urne
mais que la sélection des candidats
éligibles faites par les parties conduit
à une professionnalisation du métier
politique et une fermeture de ces
métiers à des pans entiers de la
population
si notre assemblée était composée non
pas de personnalités élues mais de
citoyens tirés au sort le problème de la
représentativité disparaîtrait mais
pourquoi nous ne soyons pas les premiers
à faire ça les grecs sont souvent cités
en pionnier de la démocratie et bien il
ne votaient pas tant que ça en effet
pour faire tourner le pouvoir parmi les
citoyens les grecs utilisaient
abondamment le tirage au sort
la boule est l'organe chargé de
confectionner les lois étaient composés
de 500 citoyens tirés au sort parmi les
volontaires et renouveler alignement
il en était de même pour le tribunal
l'ailier remarquons qu aujourd'hui nous
conservons cette tradition d'avoir des
jurés d'assises tirés au sort qui ont un
rôle central dans la décision
mais comment en est on à leur arrivée à
notre système actuel
pourquoi faut-il des représentants qu'il
est nécessaire d'élire on s'est posé la
question du bon système politique au
moment de la révolution française et
sans lui accorder plus d'importance
qu'il en a dans la construction de notre
système politique
regardons les idées de la bcs la bcs
était un député du tiers état lors des
états généraux est il dit dans un
discours le 7 septembre 1789 devant
l'assemblée constituante que je cite le
concours c'est à dire la participation
des citoyens à la loi peut s'exercer de
deux manières les citoyens peuvent
donner leur confiance à quelques uns
d'entre eux donc ça c'est la
représentation
l'autre manière d'exercer son droit à la
formation de la loi et de concourir
soi-même immédiatement à la faire ce
concours immédiat est ce qui caractérise
la véritable démocratie
le concours média lui désigne le
gouvernement représentatif
la différence entre ces deux systèmes
est énorme alors bon jusque là rien de
surprenant mais il conclu le débat ainsi
la france n'est point et ne peut pas
être une démocratie le peuple dans un
pays qui n'est pas une démocratie ne
peut parler ne peut agir que par ses
représentants
et l'élection serait donc là pour
choisir ses représentants
ensuite les élus ont les mains libres
c'est selon c'est yes indispensables
pour leur permettre d'avoir un débat et
de modifier leur avis alors je suis
assez partisan d'un système
représentatif bien que ce soit non
démocratique par essence selon seyes je
considère que la décision politique est
un processus long qui prend du temps et
qu'il semble nécessaire de pouvoir
déléguer mais s'il faut des
représentants il ne faut pas qu'il se
transforme en une caste fermé je
voudrais vous convaincre qu'en désignant
par l'élection nous introduisons de très
nombreux biais et que si nous utilisons
le seul outil qu'est l'élection pour
choisir nos représentants
alors nous nous faisons mal représentés
les logiques de l'élection la clôture et
la professionnalisation du monde
politique pousse les élus à chercher la
réélection mais pas forcément c'est leur
métier mais cela n'aide pas à avoir des
élus au service de l'intérêt général
un problème plus grand encore et que
cette captation du pouvoir par les
élites politiques et justifier a
posteriori par une incapacité du peuple
à se gouverner lui-même seuil est
toujours le même disait en effet je cite
la très grande pluralité de nos
concitoyens n'a ni assez l'instruction
ni assez de loisirs pour vouloir
s'occuper des lois qui doivent gouverner
la france
leur avis est donc de nommer des
représentants mais j'ai déjà entendu cet
argument on cherche systématiquement à
éliminer certaines catégories du pouvoir
politique soit à cause de leur couleur
de peau de leur sexe de leur niveau
d'éducation etc
et ce ne sont même pas des processus
conscient on ne se dit pas tous les
jours tiens je ne vais pas voter pour
elle c'est une femme non mais toujours
est il que petit à petit des
trajectoires de vie font que les femmes
paraissent moins légitimes sont moins
disponibles pour s'engager trop haut
trop affairés à s'occuper de la maison
leur supposée espace de prédilection
l'élection n'est pas mauvaise en soi
c'est un très bon moyen de donner son
avis le problème est que lorsque nous
choisissons quelqu'un
voulons prendre le meilleur aristote
disait que l'élection et aristocratique
car elle pousse à choisir les meilleurs
et les meilleurs qui sait c'est celui
qui nous semble plus légitime
c'est celui qui a été désigné par son
camp comme étant le plus légitime et
tous ces petits processus de sélection
d'orientation sont grandement influencé
par les représentations qu'on a de ce
qu'est quelqu'un de légitime pour
s'occuper de la politique c'est ainsi
qu'on se retrouve avec 26 % de femmes à
l'assemblée et 0 2 % d'ouvriers
ce n'est pas parce qu'ils sont moins
compétents mais c'est parce qu'ils sont
moins légitime aux yeux de la société
et pourtant rien n'indique que nos élus
sont compétents laissez vous laissez moi
vous prendre un exemple concret dans
lequel les élus ne peuvent pas être
compétent on a souvent le débat en
france de l'introduction d'une part de
proportionnelle à l'assemblée nationale
les deux grands partis de gouvernement
n'en veulent pas de peur de perdre des
élus et le petit parti e la souhaitent
non mais sérieusement on ne va pas
confier la réforme de notre système
électoral à des personnes qui ont été
élus par ce même système dans n'importe
quel pays ça s'appellerait un conflit
d'intérêt évident ça la colombie
britannique au canada l'a bien compris
elle a cherché en 2004 à réformer son
mode de scrutin électoral
c'était un scrutin majoritaire très
similaire au nôtre qui faisait qu'un
parti avec une courte majorité dans les
suffrages pouvait remporter le parlement
dans sa totalité
on a tiré au sort quinze mille huit
cents personnes sur les listes
électorales en excluant les personnes
déjà élu cette sélection était paritaire
est représentative de cinq groupes d'âge
il ya eu mille volontaires pour
participer à des réunions d'information
à l'issue desquelles on a tiré au sort 2
citoyens
un homme et une femme dans chaque
circonscription l'assemblée ainsi formés
et est paritaire est composée de 160
citoyens
issu de la société civile ces citoyens
ont été formés pendant trois mois par
des experts pendant les week-ends ils
ont reçu une indemnité de 150 dollars
par jour et leurs frais étaient
remboursés s'ennuie suivi deux mois
d'audiences publiques pendant lesquelles
les membres de l'assemblée ont reçu tous
les citoyens près de 3000 qui
souhaitaient s'exprimer sur le sujet il
eu ensuite deux mois de délibérations à
l'issue desquelles l'assemblée a fait
une proposition concrète de réforme de
son mode de scrutin électoral
cette proposition visait à mettre en
place un scrutin plus complexes visant
un meilleur pluralisme alors
malheureusement ces propositions ont été
rejetées par un référendum
mais c'est ce que je pourrais appeler un
véritable processus démocratique
les citoyens ont été capables sur
insurgés restreint de se former de
produire des propositions sans parler
sans passer par l'élection
alors est ce qu'on pourrait faire ça
tout le temps partout il ya plusieurs
champs d'application au tirage au sort
il ne faudrait pas voir le tirage au
sort comme un remplaçant de toutes nos
élections actuelles sans changer les
institutions non
cela nécessite un profond changement et
une redéfinition des tâches politiques
de chacun je pense que les assemblées de
citoyens ont toute leur légitimité pour
azur pour agir sur des sujets restreint
des limites et sur lequel il est
possible de se former
je pense aussi qu elles ont un rôle à
jouer en créant des assemblées de
contrôle de nos élus pour valider leur
décision et se placer en garde-fou
démocratique
il ne faudrait pas voir que des
avantages au tirage au sort on ne va pas
remplacer nos 600 mille élus dont une
immense majorité d'élus locaux par des
citoyens tirés au sort tout d'un coup de
nombreuses questions restent en suspens
concernant le caractère obligatoire ou
non d'un mandat si jamais on est tirés
au sort il ne faudrait pas confondre
tirage au sort et démocratie directe
dans lequel tous les citoyens prennent
part au processus de décision
il semble aussi utopique de penser que
cela éliminera totalement la corruption
ou la formation d'une élite dirigeante
mais de le mée de tous les problèmes que
je viens d'évoquer jusqu alors
il y en a un qui semble insoluble c'est
que celui qui vous parle aujourd'hui
pour changer de système politique est un
homme de sexe masculin blancs issus des
catégories sociales favorisées et
étudiants dans une grande école il
aurait été très peu probable de voir ici
à ma place une femme de couleur de peau
différente et venant de l'université et
c'est symptomatique de l'origine de la
légitimité des personnes parlant de
politique sur la place publique
seule une très faible part de la
population semble se sentir légitime et
paraît légitime pour parler de politique
donc
ne comptez pas sur moi pour vous
apporter un système clé en main ou tout
fonctionnera tant qu'on n'aura pas
compris que toutes les personnes même
socialement dominé peuvent et doivent
parler dans nos institutions nous ne
serons pas en démocratie
ce que je veux c'est que la question de
nos institutions politiques et des
processus de décision soit au coeur de
nos débats et je pense que le tirage au
sort est un outil formidable pour
produire des décisions qui font
consensus et créer des assemblées de
contrôle de nos élus je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]